foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hello this is Sky News at one it's two
o'clock here in Cross Genco in Poland
where thousands of Ukrainian refugees
are arriving looking for safety
sanctuary and security
the seventh day of violence 21 dead in
kharkiv Russia claims to have captured
person the fight over Ukraine's Freedom
intensifies
the two sides to hold a second round of
talks as the outskirts of Kiev or hit
and the convoys continues its slow
advance to the capital
tension as tanks Advanced checkpoints in
operations as the city's mayor says his
people are ready for battle
the enemy is pulling its troops closer
to the capital billers workfor was
shelled last night fighting continued in
Butcher and hostimo we are getting ready
and we will defend our city
Ukraine's president stands firm in the
capital claiming almost 6 000 Russians
have been killed in six days of War
triumph over tyranny Joe Biden Praises
Ukraine's bravery with a vow to force
President Putin to pay the price of his
deadly actions
when dictators do not pay a price for
their aggression they cause more chaos
they keep moving
Mutual status at the Paralympics
athletes from Russia and Belarus will be
allowed to compete but not in the name
of their countries and
foreign
MPS unite in Applause as the Ukrainian
Ambassador attends pmqs in the comments
[Music]
hello good afternoon this is Sky News at
one live from Cross Genco in Poland one
of eight border crossing points with
Ukraine today is tens of thousands of
families in Russia's Firing Line fear
for their future President Putin's
forces have taken control of a southern
Fort City that's been claimed
well let's take you through the latest
developments today another round of
talks between Ukraine and Russia is
expected to take place later on today
Russia says it's in control of the
southern city of Curson while kharkiv in
the East is under constant attack and
Russian and Belarusian athletes will be
allowed to compete as neutrals at the
Paralympics Winter Games which starts in
Beijing on Friday
news has verified the following video of
a missile strike in kharkiv the second
largest city in Ukraine
the attack caused damage to a university
and a government building which our
opposite one another they are located in
the center of kharkiv and this strike
follows yesterday's attack on the city's
Freedom Square
news has also verified the following
video of a residential area to the
northwest of Kiev
located in the city of urban which is
around 16 miles away from the Ukrainian
Capital City the footage shows damage to
a building after an attack from Russian
forces
this morning Ukraine's President
Vladimir zielinski reacted to some of
the latest developments
just think about this figure almost 6
000 Russians died Russian servicemen
within six days of War a figure without
the enemy's losses during the past night
six thousand to receive what to receive
Ukraine it's impossible it will not
happen with rockets it will not happen
with bombs tanks any strikes we are on
our land and there will be an
international tribunal to prosecute them
for the war against us
well within the last hour Ukraine's
foreign minister said that Ukraine is
ready for diplomacy but will not accept
any Russian ultimatums
Russia's demands remain the same as
Putin announced in his address before
the war started where he basically
declared the war
now we are ready for talks for diplomacy
but we are not ready to accept any
Russian ultimatums at all when new talks
will take place is unknown at the moment
well joining me now is Dana magnet from
Moscow Alex Rossi is in Disney Pro in
eastern Ukraine and Sky's Adam Parsons
is in the western city of Viv at Dana in
Moscow first of all
um Dana it seems that the Russia's
Russians are advancing further and
further into Ukraine but but how is it
being portrayed in Russia and what do
people know about what is happening
they don't really know very much the
head of the independent pollster levada
said as much he said Russians don't know
really what's going on in Ukraine and
the government is closing in on the kind
of messaging that they can get
um you know this is a a government that
over decades now from Soviet times has
um excelled at propaganda and it is
going into overdrive at the moment uh
you are not allowed to call this war a
war or an invasion you can only call it
a special military operation you can
only put on
um any kind of media the uh official
lines
uh There are rules that have been sent
out to bloggers on what they can and
cannot say about this one of which says
that
um this is an operation for peace it's
just unfortunate that they have to take
these means to get peace uh there are
going to be classes at school whereby
school children
um study Vladimir Putin's speech and his
essay and take his view of the history
of Ukraine and the history of Russia as
gospel you know it's real textbook
propaganda stuff
and for example the strike on the
government building in the center of
hakib yesterday morning is being
portrayed in the media as a Ukrainian uh
strike I have yet to see how they will
react to for example the fact that
babinya the Holocaust Memorial site in
the center of Kiev was damaged when a
Russian airstrike hit the nearby
television Tower and a Communications
Network there
um and five people were killed the
defense Ministry has said nothing about
those casualties and they insist that
they only target military infrastructure
so there is a very specific message
being sent out on state TV and across
all media and in fact they've just
closed down two of the remaining
independent
um radio and TV station so it's going to
be very difficult to get your news there
are restrictions on Facebook there are
ever more restrictions coming in
essentially
um so the messaging is very tight but
for example Alexa navalny the jailed
opposition leader despite the fact that
he's sitting in jail he does manage
still to get his message out via his
lawyers and on Instagram today he posted
saying to the Russian people the only
thing that we cannot be ashamed of at
the moment is the 6 000 plus people who
were detained for attending anti-war
rallies over the last week and I call on
you all to go out every day and at the
weekends and say that you and fight
against this war he said that he'd grown
up in Soviet times and the Mantra of his
childhood had been fight for peace and
um and that that is now what people need
to do and that it is not enough just to
say we are against this war that they
actually have to go out and fight for
peace and I think there are a lot of
people in this country who are
incredibly opposed to this war then
there is a large chunk of people who
just don't know enough and are scared to
draw judgments And Then There are a
large people who swallow the kremlin's
line on what this all is and actually
think that this is a a program for peace
and that they are denotsifying a country
which is overrun with nationalists which
really couldn't be further from the
truth
hmm
Diana thank you very much for bringing
us the latest from Moscow well let's go
into Ukraine uh Alex Rossi is in the
city of danipro in the south of the
country Alex we've heard of more uh
attacks today we've heard of air uh
fights in the sky what is the situation
where you are how are people there
keeping safe
these are very grim and very dark days
for Ukraine there is fear across the
country obviously
uh but there is also huge resistance as
well now in terms of the fighting it
appears that Russia is changing its
tactics it is gearing up its assaults it
is shelling uh civilian areas uh car kid
for instance to the east of where I am
uh the mayor of kharkiv says there's no
part of that city which has now not been
hit by an artillery shell so the net is
closing around these places on the south
coast uh on the sea of azove it's a
similar picture Ukraine's pretty much
been cut off on that Coastline now very
heavy fighting we understand in the city
of Curson there are pictures now of
Russian armor in the center of that City
it's disputed whether it's fully under
the control of Russian forces but
certainly the fighting is still very
Fierce there at the moment moving uh to
the east Mario pool another
strategically important city that's
pretty much cut off from what my
contacts are telling me a very heavy
shelling there as well
um the people there the Medics are
struggling to go into certain areas uh
to find the people that have been
injured because uh it's so very heavy
that of course is in civilian areas as
well now the fear of where I am is that
Russian forces once they have
Consolidated their gains there will push
up the danipro river through zaporizia
which is fortifying itself another
important place and then towards where I
am in denipro now that would cut
Ukrainian forces pretty much in half now
the other worry for people I was talking
about the change of tactics that Russian
forces are making is that it appears
that they are now following a template
which we have seen in other conflicts in
recent history think about what happened
in Syria the the Russian Air Force
became pretty good at bombing civilian
areas and killing civilians there whole
neighborhoods I remember walking through
parts of Aleppo which have been
completely destroyed rebel-held areas in
yarmukh and Damascus again absolutely
battered by continuous Russian Firepower
then of course there's the story of what
happens in chechnya grozny particular
much of it just leveled by Russian
Artillery now I suppose the bigger
question of all of this when you see the
fierce resistance from ukrainians is
that how on Earth does Vladimir Putin
think that he can win this war he might
win the battle but how can you possibly
Forge a piece when you have annihilated
so much
of this country but certainly it's it's
um it's turning into an extremely
gruesome campaign and I think that's
borne out by the the uptick that we're
now seeing in the number of people
fleeing the country the United Nations
says those figures what more than 860
000 people have now fled this country
there are train stations which are
swamped with people trying to get on the
last trains out uh people getting in
cars heading for those border crossings
uh where you are so a really ugly
situation and extremely worrying but I
suppose the thing I'd like to underline
is that the resistance also is
enormously strong every Ukrainian that
you speak to that is Manning uh a
fortification or making Molotov
cocktails or holding a Kalashnikov
they say that they will resist this
Russian invasion with everything they
have because what they are fighting for
is so very important and that is the
soul of the country that is a country
which they hope will have a future as a
free and Democratic place
Alex Rossi there uh thank you very much
and and hope you and your team are doing
what you can to stay safe and we've got
a bit of breaking news the Deputy Prime
Minister of Ukraine has apparently
spoken to the pope and asked the pope if
he could intervene to talk to Vladimir
Putin about humanitarian corridors now
we don't have any more information about
it than that but presumably that is to
try to get people safely out of the
country if they so wish to it is a long
way from Kiev to the Viv amends the
border with Poland and we know that
there are uh Russian troops in rural
areas so um apparently the Deputy Prime
Minister of Ukraine has spoken to the
pope and asked him to speak to Vladimir
Putin there are going to be talks later
on today between the ukrainians and the
Russians we will see if that has any
bearing on that well let's go back to
Ukraine a little further west to live
and talk to my colleague Adam Parsons
who's there and Adam those who've made
sometimes pretty powerless Journeys
across the country get to live and then
from there they then sort of decide
where they're going on to possibly to
one of the crossings like this one that
I'm at but but maybe also by train
you're probably going uh to Poland from
here that station behind me has a line
that goes directly from leviv out
towards Poland it's the journey that my
team and I made yesterday coming in here
it is packed with people to be honest
with you the trains that are going off
towards Poland are very squashed and it
is all women and children and pensioners
very few men at all on those trains
those who are a very often foreign
students or workers who are here but the
refugee story of this is becoming
pressing unhcr says about 850 000 people
have left Ukraine probably around half
of them heading towards Poland that is
about two percent of the population of
Ukraine you put that into context that
was Britain that'll be about one and a
quarter million people leaving in the
course uh of a week and a lot of them
those people on the journey are around
us here Leve is a is an old uh
architecturally beautiful city but here
it is now become effectively a large
refugee camp of people coming in here
either arriving here I'm wanting to move
on to another country or in many places
remember they're coming to levit to get
away they don't want to leave Ukraine
they just want to get through a bit of
Ukraine that is safer and they have they
have come here let me show you though a
little slice of kind of humanity amidst
all this sort of grimness the resilience
for children I have to say that the time
I've been reporting on this never ceases
to amaze you can be in the midst of a
country at War you can be in a city like
this which is struggling to cope with
the influx of people and yet
nevertheless if you're a kid an
Adventure Playground is still an
Adventure Playground let's take you and
show you a bit more of what is going on
in live at the moment if you can sense
smoke in the atmosphere that's nothing
ominous it's coming from these these
braziers people around us are trying to
keep warm these are full of firewood
um and actually frankly anything else
that they can lay their hands on tends
to get burnt and so it's an accurate
atmosphere and it adds to that slightly
foreboding sense that you have you can
see that absolutely enormous uh pile of
firewood over there and on the other
side of this crowd there's a big cooking
pot uh would somebody do you probably
see it over there stirring a vast vast
container of soup the generosity of
volunteers whether it's been been on on
the Polish side of the Border or whether
it's been here in La Viv it has been
quite uh quite impressive quite
intoxicating and and here you have the
Red Cross Center where they are handing
out food and drink and giving support to
people who have ended up here and you
talk to people and everybody it sounds
obvious everybody has a story everybody
tells you a tale that all too often
involves horrendous trauma we were
talking earlier to a man called Igor his
sister Anna their extended family were
with them they had left kharkiv
yesterday they live in a flat about a
kilometer he said less than a kilometer
from where the missile struck Cocker
causing such Devastation he said when
that happened they were on their way to
the station they heard that the sound of
bombs Anna his sister told me were there
on the train and she said we were like
this with our hands above our heads uh
their their feeling is that the bombs
were in not just a military Target she
said they were aiming us and our
children and of course that's what's LED
them to leave or to leave kharkiv they
don't want to leave Ukraine though and I
think that's another part of this story
we talk about 850 000 people and of
course that number Rising all the time
leaving Ukraine there will be who knows
maybe the same number again displaced
internally within this country who have
moved out here to the West because they
think it is safe it is safe at the
moment the fighting is a long way from
here but this is still a tense and
nervous City there are roadblocks we had
to show our identity today in front of
uh in front of soldiers uh with uh
assault rifles and the air raid sirens
have already gone off a couple of times
here today those were those were drills
of course uh there are no uh
bombardments attacking certainly
attacking this city so what you've got
is this blend of people hello hello
um got the blend of young people like
this you've got people who are relieved
to be here but the irony of Lev at the
moment
is that people are relieved and happy to
be here
but nobody who's coming here actually
wanted to be in the Viv wanted to be a
home they didn't want to be at a country
in Europe at War
Adam thanks so much for that well
as Alan was saying these people are
making these these Journeys often are
really stressful Journey To Live and
then they are then coming on to other
border crossings we're just going to
move the camera around and take a look
at what's going on here at crosstenko
around at the moment
um
if you look beyond the immediate scene
um which is relatively quiet at the
moment I have to say there are a few
cars going picking people up
um but on the other side of the Border
there is a great deal happening and that
is where the cars are traveling from
inside Ukraine and depositing their
cargo a lot of abandoned cars on the
other side apparently we're seeing a lot
of things like food packets litter
because people are waiting there for
really long periods of time some have
traveled one family of 30 today set off
on the 24th from the donbass area and
the people who are on that side are
mainly men because they are the ones who
are staying behind and then as they come
across here mainly women and children
we've just seen a family being loaded
into a car here
um it's often a mum it usually seems to
be weighed down with a huge number of
bags all they can carry children with a
little backpack on usually carrying a
cuddly toy and they're also carrying
plastic bags with food they're obviously
been given a certain number of supplies
on the other side for their Journey when
they get to this side and then when they
come to this side of the Border they're
being met sometimes by Family sometimes
by friends we've seen quite a lot of
lovely reunions today people haven't
seen each other for a long time
but also uh volunteers who are coming to
pick people up we've seen cars here from
Switzerland from the Czech Republic from
Germany from Finland so people are
coming from all over Europe to help here
and then they go on to Transit centers
there are three from this particular
border where they will then be processed
they can stay for longer if they need to
if they haven't got anywhere to stay
they could then be moved on to another
part of Poland perhaps and there are
this is a relatively small border
crossing but there are two much larger
border crossings uh bigger ones which
are closer to Kiev north of here and we
are seeing a lot more supplies coming in
through those routes a lot more big
trucks and what is often Happening Here
perhaps if we look at this family here
or just load it loading into this car
what's often happening is we're seeing
cars are coming often full of stuff full
of bags of perhaps old baby clothes
um perhaps food and people in the cars
are off depositing those things with the
volunteers here and then the end car is
waiting and has been filled up with
families who are being taken back inside
Poland
well these pictures show one of the
larger border crossings and you can
really see the the tiny numbers that the
the large numbers of tiny children that
there are
we're going to take you away from these
images for now and take you across to
Beijing where we're we're getting this
press conference from the international
paralympic committee let's listen in
just 48 hours to go before the opening
ceremony of the Beijing 2022 paralympic
Winter Games they sees a very difficult
time for the whole world as well as the
paralympic movement
this week the IPC has needed to navigate
its way through to their very difficult
issues the safe passage of the Ukrainian
paralympic team to Beijing and the
breach of the Olympic troops by the
Russian and Belarus governments
it goes without saying that the ongoing
situation in Ukraine is horrific and our
thoughts prayers and well wishes are
with our member the NPC of Ukraine its
delegates athletes officials and The
Wider Ukrainian population
I am delighted to say that just hours
ago the Ukrainian team consisting of 20
athletes and nine guides are right
safely here in Beijing
this is a wonderful achievement and I'm
sure you share my delight
that they are safe and will be able to
compete at these games
for this I would like to thank the APC
management team and then Beijing 2022
organizing committee for their tireless
work behind the scenes
today the IPC governing board met to
discuss the current situation and ins
its impact on the paralympic games and
the wide up paralympic movement
as you can imagine it was a very intense
and emotional meeting with all board
members eager to share their views on
the matter at hand
over the last week the board and myself
have also had many conversations with
IPC members and we are all grateful to
you for sharing your views and opinions
on the subject
the points raise both publicly and
privately
by Our member organizations fed into the
internal discussions we had over the
course of the last several days
the 14 strong board which features eight
paralympians was United in his
combination of both Russian and Belarus
governments for breaching the U.N
resolution in the week leading up to the
opening of the games
the board was also unanimous in deciding
that such actions could not go unnoticed
or unaddressed
in deciding what action to take the
board was Guided by the ipc's core
principles which include a commitment to
political neutrality and impartiality
and an unwavering belief in the
transformative power of sport
these are key components of the new IPC
Constitution that was approved at the
2021 IPC General Assembly held just over
three months ago
the board also needed to work within the
framework of the IPC handbook the rules
and regulations that govern the
paralympic movement and which are
approved by the IPC membership
in that respect it is currently not a
membership obligation for an IPC member
to ensure compliance with the Olympic
truths
we were also conscious that decisions of
this magnitude invariably end up in low
codes
therefore our decision making needed to
be driven not by emotions but by our
constitutional purpose and handbook
this approach is consistent with how we
tackle the Russian dopping crisis ahead
of the Rio 2016 paralympic games
back then we were able to prove that the
RPC was unable to ensure compliance with
and enforcement of the ipc's anti-doping
code and the world and tied up in code
these obligations are a fundamental
requirement for all national paralympic
committees and clearly highlighted in
the IPC handbook
this time round the situation is
different
there is no Nexus between the recent
actions of the Russian and Belarusian
governments and our membership
obligations
in particular there currently is no
membership obligation for an IPC member
to ensure compliance with the Olympic
truths this means that within the
current IPC rules framework
suspending either NPC Russia or NPC
Belarus for breaching the Olympic truths
is something that would be overturned in
the German court of law
working within the parameters of the APC
Constitution and the IPC handbook the
IPC governing board has taken the
stronger possible action in response to
the gross violation of the Olympic
truths by the government of Russia and
Belarus
the actions we have taken were announced
earlier this evening ahead of them
becoming public we informed Beijing 2022
the ioc and briefed all IPC members
participating in the Beijing 2022
paralympic Winter Games
the measures are as follows
the RPC and PC Belarus will participate
as neutrals at the Beijing 2022
paralympic winter games under the
following conditions
all their athletes support Personnel
will participate in an individual
capacity as neutral athletes support
personnel they will compete under the
paralympic flag and the paralympic
anthem
they will not be included in the medals
table
the RPC delegation must cover the RPC
symbol on their uniforms in all official
ceremonies and sporting competitions the
Belarus delegation must cover the
Belarus flag on the uniforms in all
official ceremonies and sporting
competitions
All Tech and co-officials attending the
games from Russian Belarus will be
listed as neutrals under the paralympic
flag as will coaches from the respective
countries involved with other teams
the approach set out on points one and
two above will also be followed in
relation to the participation of the RPC
and NPC Belarus in the 10 Paris boats
governed by the IPC
the IPC governing board has also decided
both in its role as the global guardian
of paralympic movement and as
International federations for 10 Paris
ports that it will not hold any events
in Russia or Belarus until further
notice this will include World on
European championships as well as all
sanctional level competitions such as
World Series World Cups and Grand Prix
events
the APC governing board also recommends
that all Paris support international
federations region organizations and the
iosds follow the same approach
an extraordinary IPC General Assembly
will be held in 2022
and the IPC Constitution six months
notice must be given before this event
can take place at this meeting IPC
members will be invited to vote upon
weather ensuring compliance with the
Olympic truths should be a membership
requirement and therefore
any IPC member breaching that
requirement in the future could face
suspension or termination under the IPC
rules
and whether to suspend or terminate the
membership of Russian paralympic
committee and Belarus paralympic
committee
the paralympic honor bestowed to
Vladimir Putin President of Russia has
been withdrawn
paralympic orders the highest Accolade
can be presented within the paralympa
movement we will be withdrawn from the
following individuals
Dimitri journeychenko president of Sochi
2014 organizing committee now Deputy
Prime Minister of the Russian Federation
Dmitry Kozak Deputy Prime Minister of
Russia now Deputy Chief of Staff of the
presidential executive office
olexido Molotov chief of interagency
security command centers such a 2014 now
Deputy foreign minister
Alexander gorovoy Deputy Chief of
interagency security Command Center
Sochi 2014 now first Deputy interior
minister
given the time constraints and the need
for the APC to focus on the delivery of
a safe and successful problem pigmented
games under these unprecedented
circumstances the IPC governing board
will reconvene after the games to
further discuss this matter and any
additional action that may be required
it is deeply disappointing that search
action is required however the APC
governing board believes it to be
necessary in order to hold governments
to account for actions that impact
directly on the paralympic movement the
paralympic games and paralympic athletes
this is especially so given the origins
of the paralympic movement arising out
of the horrific events of Second World
War
now that this decision has been made I
expect all participating in PCS to treat
the neutral athletes as they would any
other athletes at these games no matter
how difficult this may be
unlike their respective governments
these paralympic athletes and officials
are not aggressors they are here to
compete in a sport event like everybody
else
the eye of the world will be watching
the paralympic Winter Games in the
coming days it is vital we show the
world leaders through our sport that we
can unite as human beings and that our
true power is fun when we promote peace
understanding and inclusion
this is at the core of what the
paralympic movement does and what it
stands for we should not lose sight of
this now no matter what the
circumstances
in some of my conversations during the
past several days I've heard a sentiment
that sometimes you just have to do the
right thing no matter what the
consequence
I suspect some of you in this room may
be thinking the same I want to take a
moment to address this view because I
think it is misplaced in these
circumstances and actually can result in
real damage to our movement
the question I will ask is the right
thing for whom
the second thing I'd offer is that being
faithful to our Constitution and
membership obligations is in fact doing
the right thing
we are membership and our constitutional
purpose our Collective belief in the
power of sport it's not something that
we put on and take off whenever it suits
us instead the principle of political
neutrality and the genuine belief in the
transformative power of sport must be
our North Star our strength or perhaps
our Lifeboat especially when we find
ourselves facing the darkest side of
humanity these commitments are ones to
embrace not shed during these critical
times
to close I hope I have been able to
share with you the difficulty of today's
decision at the IPC we pride ourselves
on sticking to our principles when
making difficult decisions
today we could not abandon the
principles that have got us this far no
matter what the public pressure
as a membership-based organization we
value the views and the ongoing support
of our members this is why we are eager
to organize this extraordinary General
Assembly later this year rather than
wait until 2023 General Assembly so that
the members can have more of a say on
this matter
thank you
thank you Andrew I'd now like to pass
the mic to yet skirt Fisher the
chairperson of the IPC athletes Council
let's go over to you
thank you Greg
good evening everyone as a chairperson
of the IBC athletes council is
disappointing for the athletes and all
game stakeholders that with 48 hours to
go before the opening ceremony the dog
is not of sport but global politics
we've also been greatly concerned to
ensure that the Ukrainian paralympic
delegation could safely get to the games
and it is wonderful that they arrived
earlier this day
since this Crisis began the IPC athletes
Council has been eager to listen to the
views of the global global para well
that they're the international
paralympic committee who have confirmed
what we heard a little earlier today
that um the paralympians for for both
Russia and Belarus can compete the game
starts on Friday but it will be
competing neutrally also announced some
personal sanctions against both
president Peter and president lukashenka
of Belarus we're going to talk more
about this in a moment but first there's
a bit of breaking news from the mayor of
maripole this is a city in the south of
Ukraine he is reporting Mass casualties
as a report of a sustained Russian
attack so maripole we know we know that
this is an area that the Russians had
Advanced upon the mayor there says that
there have now been Mass casualties
there as the result of a sustained
Russian attack we'll bring you more
details on that as we get them at Sky
News but let's Let's cross to Sky's
Sports correspondent Tom palminter who
joins us now and and Tom heard there
more details from the international
paralympic committee uh also really
they're expressing how difficult it is
for them to make these decisions we've
seen so many sporting events stepping
away from Russia and Belarus but but
making the point there that the
paralympians who are expected to take
part on Friday are not the aggressors uh
and that we can unite as human beings
and promote peace understanding and
inclusion and they're hoping that that
perhaps some cut some good will come of
the Russians and belarusians competing
what has been the UK reaction so far Tom
as you say the IPC are trying to pick
their way through this and are trying to
rely on their rules and handbooks to
allow them to have
come to decisions that are kind of
challengeable and that will stand up if
they are challenged further down the
line and the position that they have
come to with the organizers of the
winter Paralympics is that Russian and
Belarusian athletes will be allowed to
compete but as neutral athletes and that
the Russian paralytic parallel Olympic
Committee sorry uh will not appear on
the medals table
and that is a position that has divided
a lot of opinion uh across the
paralympic community uh they're a fair
degree of anger we were talking earlier
to Richard Whitehead one of the
prominent uh runners in the Paralympics
who appeared at the Winter Games and the
summer Paralympics as well and he told
us that he was very disappointed with
the decision he said that it doesn't
send out the right message it's not a
firm enough stance from the IPC and that
has been echoed today by Nadine dorries
the culture secretary who has
responsibility for sport within her
Department she says I'm extremely
disappointed with the IPC this is the
wrong decision and I call on them to
reconsider they must join the rest of
the world in condemning this barbaric
Invasion by Banning Russian and
belarussian athletes from competing she
goes what goes on we will consider the
full range of options in protest this
decision in consultation with UK Sport
and the British paralympic Association I
will also be meeting with my
International counterparts this week to
discuss how we can respond collectively
and the clock has been very much ticking
for the winter Paralympics because they
start on Friday there is due to be a
team that was made up of Russian
athletes taking part in the para ice
hockey this weekend so they were really
up against a tight deadline but the
decision that they have come to is one
that is certainly not fully well
received across the paralympic community
and further afield
and and Tom uh I understand that Everton
uh football club is stepping away from
its Russian sponsors as well we've heard
from another other uh football teams
who've done this already
yeah they're one of a number of sporting
clubs who have links to Russian uh based
money and really their collection is one
of Alisha osmanov who is an usbek
oligarch who has had a commercial
relationship with the club for some time
sponsoring their training ground and
also has the naming rights for Everton's
new stadium a big centerpiece of their
plan in the next few years is to move
from gooderson park down to the
waterfront on the river mersey and Mr
usmanov very much part of that financing
of that big move and so Everton have
been trying to work out how they go
forward they have shirt sponsors they
have various sponsors connected to the
club that are connected to Mr usmanov's
businesses in Russia and the club have
said they can confirm that it's
suspended with immediate effects all
commercial sponsorship arrangements with
the Russian companies USM megaphone and
Yota so these are seismic decisions
being taken Within bought at speed and
as we can see a variety of standpoints
being taken some much more Hardline than
others than the Paralympics have said
that they have tried to plot a course
that respects their rules and principles
and is also not in a not going to
penalize those athletes who as the
Paralympics have said are not the
aggressors and they expect during the
Paralympics in Beijing for them to be
treated like any other athletes
thanks a lot Tom now President Biden has
used his State of the Union Address last
night so that Russia is now more
isolated from the world than ever before
and he said that Vladimir Putin will pay
a high price for invading Ukraine
six days ago
Russia's Vladimir Putin sought to shake
the very foundations of the Free World
thinking he could make it Bend
to his menacing ways
but he badly miscalculated he thought he
could roll into Ukraine and the world
would roll over instead he met with a
mall a wall of strength he never
anticipated or imagined he met the
Ukrainian people but the next few days
weeks and months will be hard on them
Putin has Unleashed violence and chaos
but while he may make gains on the
battlefield he'll pay a continuing high
price over the long run
well from Washington Sally Lockwood
joins me now and Sally what has been the
reaction to the State of the Union
Address do Americans think that Biden is
doing enough for what is happening in
Ukraine
well it's been largely bipartisan
support here in America for Joe Biden's
response to this Ukraine crisis of
course some Republicans are critical
some saying that it's too little too
late but it's an uncomfortable position
for the Republican Party criticizing Joe
Biden's foreign policy on Russia when of
course they embraced Donald Trump who
has uh flattered Vladimir Putin on
countless occasions not least since this
invasion of Ukraine but what we heard
from Joe Biden last night at this State
of the Union Address was stuff that we'd
largely heard before but this time it
was to a much bigger domestic audience
where he framed this battle between
democracy and autocracy one new Step
that he did announce though was that
he's Banning Russian aircraft from U.S
airspace and he vowed to go after
Russian oligarchs he did though also
Express concern about the rise in Energy
prices and where this war will end now
Kamala Harris the vice president of his
been doing the rounds on some of the US
networks this morning and she talked
about the impact that Western sanctions
is already having on Russia's economies
saying that the ruble has tanked the
stock market and Russia is essentially
closed she said in that Russia's credit
rating is now junk one thing to look
ahead to in around an hour and a quarter
from now the U.N general assembly is
reconvening its emergency session in New
York in response to this crisis in
Ukraine and we could get a vote on that
resolution as early as today a vote on
Russia's actions and a call to the end
of their invasion of Ukraine of course
what difference will that make it
doesn't seem that Vladimir Putin has
given much response if any to Western
actions so far and even last night in
that State of the Union Address Joe
Biden actually acknowledged publicly
first time that he's not he's not
certain where Vladimir Putin is going to
stop quite a chilling thing for the
president of the United States to say
and certainly at least publicly Joe
Biden has not offered any sort of
compromise to Vladimir Putin and
Vladimir Putin hasn't offered any sort
of reaction in terms of this Western
response and sanctions so far certainly
perhaps figuring that at this stage
having gone this far he may achieve more
by continuing this brutal invasion of
Ukraine
Sally thanks very much
well the human rights council's right
now holding its third day of talks in
Geneva with several ministers giving
speeches on the situation in Ukraine
Poland's foreign minister called on
Russia to stop the war and respect the
human rights of the people of Ukraine
the horror that was imposed on my
country's neighbor has already caused
deaths and suffering including among
civilians and constitutes the most
deplorable degree of violations of
international human rights law we call
on Russia
to immediately stop this war to withdraw
troops and to respect human rights and
humanitarian needs of the people of
Ukraine according to obligations
stemming from international law
is our correspondent Laura bundock in
Brussels and and diplomacy is continuing
today Laura but is there any suggestion
that Vladimir Putin is paying any
attention or heed to it
known whatsoever but that doesn't stop
the Diplomatic efforts being made in
Geneva and we've been hearing Nation
after Nation making similar statements
similar declarations against Putin's
invasion of Ukraine similar pleas for
him to withdraw his forces and to
re-engage with the diplomacy it was
interesting hearing the Irish foreign
minister Simon Covey when he he got up
and he said this crisis will only be
resolved with political dialogue so
there is very much the hope there that
it might end with that kind of political
dialogue but no sign of it yet one
interesting player in all of this is
Emmanuel macron the French president
he's due to make a state address a
little later on this evening and
remember he has always had a closer
perhaps relationship with Putin he's
he's ever since becoming president try
to develop a special relationship with
him the two have been pictured on a few
occasions notably at the beginning of
last month at that huge long table and
there was a phone call on Monday a
90-minute phone call between been the
two now Putin
president macron asking for Putin to
stop attacking civilian areas and the
light clearly that hasn't happened but I
think it's seen as an important
relationship because it is at least one
Communication channel That Remains open
for now as I say though this diplomatic
effort still ongoing very much a sign
that world leaders trying to isolate
President Putin isolate the Kremlin is
it stopping his actions well it
certainly isn't at the moment because
while the diplomacy continues it's clear
that Putin's Invasion does too
Laura thanks very much
well let's get a closer look now at the
situation on the ground in Ukraine and
the Strategic maneuvers of the war Let's
cross to Kamali Melbourne at the Sky
News Center Kamali
Jane thank you very much well let's now
uh take a closer look at the situation
on the ground as Russian forces continue
to encroach on Ukraine drawn by Michael
Clark our defense analyst for a close
look at this so Michael just tell us
where we are with the fight for Ukraine
at the moment as the Russian forces are
arrayed the number of points around the
country yes mean the Russians began this
with what I would call a plan B which
was to do it the way Western forces
would have done it with relatively light
forces moving quite quickly from the
border to surround key areas and moving
quickly on Kiev get rid of the
government declare themselves a new
government and that was all supposed to
be done within 72 hours hasn't worked
they've made a big mess of it and the
ukrainians have fought back ferociously
so now they've gone to plan a which is
what they know how to do which is to
move in more slowly with heavier armor
Siege trains as they say down the uh
nipra Valley as you've you've pointed
out there in order to surround the big
cities and this has become a war of the
Cities it's a north-south war at the
moment but it will will revolve around
the cities the ukrainians can't defend
the whole country so they defended the
cities and the Russians are now moving
in on all of those cities and we're
focusing on some of the cities in more
detail Carson carcavina the latest news
we've got of Mary Paul in a moment but
denipro is interesting at the moment
isn't it as well because the the
defender there the Ukrainian armed for
is an area of about three million people
it's big industrial areas about one
million people in the city and the
leader of nipro uh mikola lucascher has
said that he said I've got a million
people under arms the Russians are 90
miles away I will turn this into a new
Stalingrad and I believe him well that
may well happen in the coming days let's
take a look close look at the fight for
the south of the country focusing in on
the cities of Kirsten Odessa and Mario
poll now let's uh talk about Kirsten to
start with now we understand that this
city is still being contested by both
Russian and of course Ukrainian forces
and also Mario poll in recent hours
we've seen the the latest from the mayor
there saying that the city's coming
under heavy bombardment constant bomba
and they are running out of water as the
Russian forces continue to attack yes I
mean two key places here kirshan where
they're still fighting a major city and
that again should have fallen quite
quickly but it didn't
um the Russians are clearly trying to
create a land Corridor between the uh
the territories that they held in the
donbass through to Crimea which was
annexed in 2014 Mario poll right on the
edge of the disputed donbess area should
have fallen within hours we've been
saying that for days now and according
to the Ukrainian government they are
still holding on in marital I don't know
how they're doing it they're coming
under great pressure but there's some
sort of Alamo going on there at some
point the Russians almost certainly will
link up all of this southern area and
then they will start to push North up
the nipra valley to unite the north and
south of the country which they hope
that they will have taken okay well uh
Michael let's just take a quick look now
if we can at kharkiv where we have seen
some more heavy fighting there has been
a Russian elements that we understand
have uh
lifted into the city of course still
being defended by the ukrainians there
was that attack on Freedom Square
yesterday as well so uh we are seeing
that this is under heavy uh contestation
by both sides yeah carplay the Second
City very important city too and the
Russians look as if they're now adopting
their plan a which is the way they
always do these things which is to
surround the city probably come and get
it from the East Airborne drops we think
probably in the west
um and they will sit outside the city
bombard the Strategic centers as they
see them they won't worry too much about
civilian casualties and then they
probably would would uh start to bombard
civilian areas in order to break the
spirit of the civilians and then just
move in and what happens in kharkiv in
the next two or three days almost
certainly will be what will happen in
Kiev uh probably sometime next week okay
Michael Clarke for now thank you very
much let's get throw it back to Jane on
the Polish Ukrainian border
um we're gonna talk to lithuania's Vice
Minister of Defense in a moment marguise
above Pierce but let's just take a quick
look at what's happening behind us these
trucks have been arriving uh backwards
and forwards throughout the day they're
bringing supplies which are being
patched down the line
um this this one behind me he's got
nappies uh food stuffs toilet rolls
those sorts of things there's just a
constant stream of them here at the
border uh coming but but let's bring in
uh the vice Minister of Defense from
Lithuania Margaritas
um very good to talk to you I understand
that our foreign secretary the UK
foreign secretary list trust is is
traveling to Lithuania today and there's
going to be meeting her counterparts
from a number of of countries there
um How concerned are you in Lithuania
about what is happening in Ukraine
I think everyone is concerned it's not
only in Lithuania I think in all in NATO
countries and worldwide I would say the
reaction uh towards Russian Russian
actions is a worldwide and very unite so
everyone is concerned because we see uh
that Russia does not respect any
rules agreements and so on of course we
saw this is that this is coming we we
saw uh the aggressiveness of Russia we
saw a military integration with with
Belarus and other similar things but I
think till the last moment nobody really
believed that they can cross this red
line and and we see that we cross this
red line with full invasion on on
Ukraine and of course it is it is
worrying
uh what about belarus's involvement
though of course a country right next to
yours
I think when we talk about the current
uh War we should say that Belarus
participates fully in in Russian
campaign uh I'm not talking about their
soldiers but we are allowing the
authority their territory to be used by
Russian military to fire Rockets to
deploy troops and so on I so in our
reaction we should see that this is a
Russian belarussian war against against
Ukraine and against the West
what do you think the West could do
should do now
I think we are doing already a lot I
think what is uh what is important now
in the coming days to continue and and
to increase to increase military
assistance uh because this is really
needed to help ukrainians to to fight
back to withstand the Russian uh actions
and to push back uh Russians not to
allow them to gain more territory so
this is key and we should definitely
increase that military assistance of
course in parallel the process on uh
sanctions are ongoing and Via everyday
communicating more and more uh more
heavy sanctions but I think in a short
term the only thing which can stop uh
Russia is uh military assistance in
Ukraine they will not stop if Ukraine
will not stop them
okay uh Margaret abavikius uh the vice
Minister of Defense of Lithuania thank
you so much for joining us today on Sky
thank you well as we're here at the
Polish at Ukrainian border we know that
almost 700 000 refugees have already
fled the Russian invasion more than half
have been arriving at places like this
one uh let's bring in from the Viv on
Western Ukraine UNICEF spokesperson
James eldad and James it does seem I
have to say really quite well organized
in terms of of people coming they're
being met by people they're not really
having to stand around for a long time
which is fantastic but of course each
person coming across here is leaving
their life behind aren't they
yeah spot on and I'm really glad to hear
that because of course the people I'm
speaking to the women I were just with
at a shelter I spent the last two or
three nights in in bunkers or not in
bunkers but under bombardment in Kiev or
Hakeem and then they've made that long
journey okay it's only 500 kilometers
but maybe it's taken them 24 hours in
freezing conditions to where I am in
live and then they're at a train station
cold and now they're now they're getting
sheltered to that next step to where you
are so I'm really glad to hear that
because yeah the trauma the stress I'm I
I I've seen it before but maybe not on
this scale not right now it's just um
that train station just Echoes with
tears as you say husband and wives
farewell each other fathers explain to
their seven-year-old daughters why dad
is leaving and the little girls off with
mum to a country she's not heard of
it's heartbreaking isn't it James and
what's striking me is how little they're
often carrying you know people who've
got cars have kind of got loads of stuff
packed into those great big sort of
heavy duty shopping bags you know they
haven't got their cases and stuff
they've just thrown stuff into bags and
people who are on foot are just coming
across with what they can carry it's
absolutely heartbreaking James Ida from
UNICEF I'm afraid we're out of time but
it's really good to talk to you today
thank you very much very much for
joining us from the Vive um you're
you're watching us here now at the
Ukrainian border between Poland and
Ukraine it's been a heartbreaking
morning I have to say watching people
coming across here but at least there
are people on the other side to meet
them and to try to offer them some help
for this next stage in the conflict stay
with Sky News foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]